in Schulenberg in Niedersachsen steht
die bramkebrücke am okeral Stausee jetzt
hat die zuständige Straßenbaubehörde
diese Zufahrt zum Ort gespart auf
unbestimmte Zeit obwohl seit Jahren klar
ist dass die Brücke erneuert werden muss
gibt's keine fertigen Pläne für einen
Neubau Schulenberg liegt jetzt am Ende
einer Sackgasse mit heftigen
folgen also ich fahre jetzt die doppelte
Strecke anstatt 18 km 36 km ich brauche
pro Fahrt eine halbe Stunde länger das
heißt am Tag eine Stunde das sind im
Jahr 220 Stunden alleine was es
Rettungswege angibt das ist eine FAS es
gibt genau zwei zugewege einmal über die
Brücke einen anderen Weg die Brücke ist
gesperrt wenn an dem anderen Weg noch
irgendwas passiert die Straße gesperrt
werden muss dann kommt hier niemand mehr
her die bramke Brücke ist rund 80 Jahre
alt und für Schulenberg die
lebenswichtige direkte Verbindung zur
Bundesstraße
498 seit 2013 gibt's Beschränkungen für
den Schwerlastverkehr spätestens seitdem
ist klar die Brücke muss erneuert werden
doch es tut sich nichts Ende 2023 macht
die niedersächsische Straßenbaubehörde
die Brücke von einem auf den anderen Tag
komplett dicht die Planung für den
Neubau ist nicht abgeschlossen wann die
Bagger kommen weiß auch niemand statt
den kurzen Weg über die Brücke zu nehmen
müssen die schulenberge jetzt einen
schier endlosen Umweg fahren von einem
Ende der Brücke zum anderen sind es nun
24 km für viele geht's um die
Existenz bei besten Winterwetter wie wir
es jetzt letztes Wochenende vorlztes
Wochenende hatten standen hier drei
Autos auf dem Parkplatz da kann ich kein
Kaffee von betreiben es wusste jeder
dass die Brücke gemacht werden muss aber
nicht erstmal 10 Jahre ins Land vergehen
lassen die niederschsische Landesbehörde
für Straßenbau und Verkehr teilt uns mit
man habe Verständnis für die Sorgen der
Menschen aber
die Planung eines solchen Bauwerks kann
nicht auf Vorrat erfolgen da die Gesetze
und Vorschriften sich stetig ändern die
Planung müsste ständig aus der Schublade
geholt und an neue rechtliche Grundlagen
angepasst werden aber die Ungewissheit
wann es hier wieder rüber geht ist für
die Menschen eine Katastrophe man weiß
ja wie solche Bauvorhaben in Deutschland
behandelt werden wie lange sowas dauern
kann und deswegen kannst D angehen dass
wir jetzt mit einmal hier in der
Sackgasse Leben am Ende der Welt quasi
und damit ich nicht einverstanden das
geht so nicht aktuell prüft die
Straßenbaubehörde ob sie einen kleinen
Forstweg durch den Wald ausbauen kann
damit es wenigstens für
Rettungsfahrzeuge eine Alternativroute
gibt ob das aber tatsächlich klappt weiß
derzeit auch niemand